i'll never forget the first time i saw
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone at
least the book cover i was in the
seventh grade and flipping through one
of those little scholastic book order
forms which they still send out today by
the way and it was really mary grand
praise cover of harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone that just immediately
drew my attention from there i read the
description and almost was instantly
hooked i knew it was a book that i just
had to read now i was a decent reader as
a kid but wouldn't say it's something i
love to do that is until harry potter
and reading harry potter really changed
everything for me long before there were
movies games theme parks i and numerous
others from my generation had already
started to imagine what hogwarts would
be like in our head what would it be
like to be sorted into a house with
others who shared a common goal and
interest and then of course to learn
about a whole new fantastical world of
magic it was really this sense of wonder
and excitement from so many kids in that
time that led to midnight launch parties
fan websites podcasts movies a theme
park and of course video games well
turns out a lot of those kids me you're
a wizard kids my age are now adults and
for more than 20 years we've been
waiting for a video game we've been
imagining a video game that would let us
step into this wonderful world not as
hairy but as our own witch or wizard you
see just recently the first official
hogwarts legacy trailer actually
eclipsed 29 million views on
playstation's youtube channel which make
it the most viewed video focusing on a
single game on their entire channel and
the third most viewed video across their
entire channel of any kind and when you
consider they have characters like
kratos nathan drake and even spider-man
how is it that a game set in the
wizarding world not even dedicated to
harry potter himself how is it that a
game like that has become one of the
most anticipated one of the most hyped
games in recent memory i think it's
simple it's shaping up to be a game that
fans have been dreaming of for more than
20 years now it's true there have been
numerous potter games over the years but
the majority have been third person
action with puzzle elements that follow
harry's story harry potter and the
philosopher's stone on pc or the
original playstation is the game many
fans think of when they remember back to
the origins of those first harry potter
video games the pc version put players
in control of harry after his arrival at
hogwarts some of the spells in the game
were flpendo alohomora guardium leviosa
lumos and incendio the spells were
contextual and while they could be cast
at any time by the player they would
only react to specific objects in the
world the pc version actually sold
really well over a million copies and
the playstation version saw ridiculous
sales numbers more than eight million
copies sold and it's actually the sixth
best selling playstation title of all
time and when you think how big of a
seller the playstation was and all the
great games that were on that system
that is a huge accomplishment top six
all time on playstation it's kind of
interesting that playstation seems to
have a marketing deal for hogwarts
legacy given that harry potter really
had some of its early beginnings right
there on the playstation now in the
years that would follow numerous other
potter games were released with varying
levels of success some are remembered
fondly others just outright bad but none
have even really attempted or even come
close to have attempted what hogwarts
legacy is trying to do now while
hogwarts legacy will keep the third
person perspective and likely some of
the action and puzzle elements from
those earlier games it's being developed
as a completely open world action rpg
and of course instead of following
harry's story this will be the story of
our own witch or wizard set in 1890 long
before harry's arrival at hogwarts even
before dumbledore's arrival at hogwarts
according to the official hogwarts
legacy website the story has players
experiencing life as a student at
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry like never before as they live
the unwritten and embark on a dangerous
journey to uncover a hidden truth of the
wizarding world so you see there we got
that fresh new mystery you know it
wouldn't be a harry potter story without
a good mystery to solve but what about
the canon and the lore that we already
know well the site also says this while
portkey games are not direct adaptations
of the books and films the games are
firmly rooted in the magical universe of
the wizarding world now this
appreciation of the source material and
the focus on so many of the things that
fans have wanted for many years the
ability to make our own adventure or as
they say live the unwritten is one of
the main reasons i think that fans are
so hyped for the project even with the
limited information we have about how
the game will actually play and even
though admittedly it's avalanche's first
attempt at an action rpg they're not a
developer that's known for this and at
this stage we truly don't know how the
game will pan out i'll be honest with
you guys we just don't know but there is
one thing that was completely clear from
the developer interviews that were shown
after the gameplay reveal trailer back
in march that i don't think anyone can
dispute and that is that avalanche as a
team they truly care about this project
that they're working on they are
passionate about it they are fans of
this world and they really want to
deliver on that promise of a wizarding
world game that ultimately captures all
that magic and lives up to the hype that
truly has been building for more than 20
years now the movies the books they've
all touched me in such a way like it
makes me want to go to
experience hogwarts makes me put in so
much more detail into this game this is
the game that they've dreamed of for 20
years
[Music]
hogwarts legacy is undoubtedly the most
bold attempt yet at creating a wizarding
world game fans can get lost in it's a
game where fans are just hoping they can
wander the halls of hogwarts for hours
on end discovering new areas discovering
new secrets hidden passages overhearing
conversations and then starting new
quests as a result of those
conversations being the witch or wizard
we want to be it truly seems like they
are shooting for the moon i mean that
fully explorable hogwarts an elaborate
spell casting system we're going to have
upgrades we're going to be able to
unlock new abilities we're going to be
able to customize the look of our
character we can visit hogsmeade we can
visit the grounds even and meet people
along the outside of hogwarts not to
mention an entirely new mystery that who
knows may even involve merlin now as i
mentioned in the beginning i still
remember all those years ago when i
first opened the pages of harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone and no doubt i
think i and many other fans who have
grown up with this series are going to
have similar memories playing hogwarts
legacy for the first time when we first
hold that game in our hands or if you're
a digital only when you first boot it up
on your system it's going to be an
incredibly memorable moment that has
been building for a long time and here's
to hoping hogwarts legacy can deliver on
what is undoubtedly a very lofty promise
it's going to be a challenge there is no
doubt that this is a tall tall order but
who knows perhaps this could just kick
off a new era for wizarding world video
games now if you'd like an extended look
at the history of all the harry potter
video games so far their charm and all
their flaws check out the video on the
right side of your screen now as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon